situé au coeur de la havane le quartier
de los sitios se retrouve sous cloche
pour au moins deux semaines
admirable d'efficacité jusqu'à la fin
2020 la stratégie sanitaire des
autorités cubaines se retrouve désormais
confronté à une première hausse
épidémique importante jusqu'au mois de
décembre
seuls quelques dizaines de cas
quotidiens a été recensé on essayait
cette semaine autour de mille nouveaux
cas chaque jour nous avons relevé le
nombre de cas confirmés le plus
important depuis le début de la pandémie
nous parlons de 1044 cas confirmés
c'est avec fatalité que les habitants de
ce quartier très fréquenté accueille
cette mise à l'isolément à cause de la
pandémie nous avons de nombreux cas dans
le quartier qui a été fermé pour éviter
la propagation
aucune personne habitant ici n'est
autorisé à entrer ou en sortir
je pense que c'était nécessaire car
c'est une zone très peuplée et il est
normal que les gens se déplacent et si
les gens se déplacent beaucoup le virus
a plus de chances de se propager
pour freiner la propagation du virus les
autorités ont également décidé de fermer
écoles bars et restaurants ou encore de
suspendre les transports publics
nocturne
par ailleurs chaque personne entrant sur
l'île doit observer une quarantaine de
cinq jours à l'issue de laquelle un
nouveau test est exigée